bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo su super
mario bros non è vero non siamo super
mario bros e siamo su mario punto ex
questi giochi punto ekson le versioni
krypi dei videogiochi normali milano
sommario andiamo su luigi ok luigi va
bene maria non andava bene ma si chiama
mario punto ex il gioco non luigi punto
ex che bello videogiochi giocare a
chieti mario ragazzone mai stato così
facile questo livello ragazzi mai stato
così facile maghetti accuse e vabbè è la
madonna
oddio mi sono mosso troppo tardi ma che
figata
ce n'è anche che smarca no vabbè dai no
da zero no spero che è tutto a valli di
clima che efficaci mar chiamati a matrix
me lo zucchero a tutti era luigi ai one
to be with you
voglio fare un gioco con te cos'è in
jeans è la madonna gesù nuovo quel
problema ma quante krypi questo gioco
veramente sono dei top squartati per
terra va bene è passato qualcosa vi
sembrava non ha capito cosa dovevo
andare di sotto
ok
c'è un fungo ma non mi sento di prendono
però prendo lo stesso e lo sapevo che
sarei morto sapeva che giorno è questo
ma gesù ascoltami mario al problema mio
e che mi sei sempre stato un po in culo
quindi non è che allora zio calmiamoci
così funghi e assieme ad amsterdam lo
sai mario che io ho parlato anche con la
tua voce è quella originale quella che
fa mamba p ha incontrato a los angeles
una volta ciò che lui barca va
ma come l'assalto quello porca eva
quanti sono e vabbè che gioco del cazzo
lebran giovane al cazzo non sono
equilibri ei giochi krypi non dovrebbero
far incazzare no mi fa pure incazzare
cioè e vabbè
rega sta diventando tragico non mi fanno
incazzare ma essendo un gioco criti
questo dovrebbe solo solo essere critici
senza deve far paura tra virgolette
mettere ansia e basta non dovrebbe fare
anche incazzare o una o l'altra non
tutte e due
porca eva ma [ __ ] da saldare
virgili semplifichiamo donna che non ho
più vite n'è una sola tac tac no sì sì
sì quanto demonio era l'ultima manca
tutto questo questo è il massimo del
filtro di youtube krypi sangue parolacce
[Musica]
raga non ci posso credere
ho un anno e mezzo ci ho messo come
faccia a faccia parte fa donna stordita
velocissimo e le ragazze sono solo che
contente quanto mi fai schifo
qualcun altro con uccidermi no quella
cosa che ti aspettano
non ho fatto in tempo partito oppure
tradurre charlie g voglio giocare con te
sei pronto no però fa bene che bello
questo gioco mi piace proprio un sacco
le regole sono semplice non devi cadere
ok
ok e fin qua e fin qua non so dove devo
arrivare e che cosa ne minchia ne sono
un vedo non vedo niente come faccio a
saperlo
porca vacca schifosa per bello che non
ti fanno neanche ripartire da questo
livello si fa ripartire da zero cioè
all'inizio del gioco proprio
ricorda luigi il tuo tempo all'inferno
conta solo su un demone
poi come cacciatori fare no oh cazzo
siamo fatta
che sfiga ho fatto un salto marco
tornare indietro però mi sa che devo
fare così proprio ok ok all e cosa dove
devo arrivare adesso aiutatemi sono più
st vita ragazzi poi dovrei iniziare
tutto da zero questa come sta messo ok
ok ok ok e jump tua sorella jump jolo va
bene
hai visto anche il demonio vuole
aiutarti mia suocera vuole aiutarmi per
ciò che è quest'area ma chi è che ha
inventato sta roba
ti fai di droghe pesanti 0 adesso
scassato le balle di zio
fatelo dire non sono poi così sicuro che
il demonio voglio ancora aiutarmi non mi
fido un'altra volta lurido solo per una
volta nella vita che fosse una roba che
azzecca per una volta nella vita cup se
qualcosa va il suo vice io non morire
verso la libertà se lui fatte pareva
luigi look back guarda indietro ma
voglio andare indietro all'ultima vita
che mi rimane
e va bene andiamo a vedere
mario ma mario
si no non fa era con cosa puzza come ha
fatto in over
ma la spinta giù così per colpa
dell'affluenza non ho capito cosa qua
grazie mario perfetto
non so come ha fatto non ho idea ma va
bene così questa era mario punto ex
ragazzi un gioco krypi basato su
supermario però ai capitoli 700 ragazzi
non ha assolutamente senso questa nuova
piastra ti fa capire che mangiare i
funghi non è proprio il massimo della
vita neanche mettere in freezer
mario è il massimo della vita però però
che siamo ha scelto ragazzi come sempre
seguito un argomento che non mi piace
anche vari social che come visto la
notizia le stasera che si scateni ci
mettiamo questo invito della ragazzi
[Musica]